[Music]
jay-j watch chimes in with his reaction
to the news that the Texans are looking
for a new GM Chris you read this tweet
so well during the break I'm gonna throw
it to you give us your son JJ what I
call JJ Watt Captain America so I was
just like I just want to win man I don't
care who how what I just want to win
go Texans and go America that is just
like a deeper version of captain Andrew
life it is a little bit yeah it's not
quite the British vampire that did
captain under Andrew Luck comes off as
that actually sounds more like captain
Andrew Loomis captain I did but it went
away soon it's almost training camp
Bryan gained went away quickly 17 months
on the job as the general manager of the
Houston Texans where do they go from
here we touched on this earlier but look
I see two different paths and this is
exactly the analysis that we had as the
Jets were looking for a new GM you can
hire somebody that the coach knows likes
and wants or you can go out and get the
best person for the job
irrespective of whether or not that
person has any prior relationship with
Bill O'Brien when you do that yeah you
hire a GM who comes to town with a short
list of coaches that that GM has been
waiting four years to work with and you
put a clock on how long until the next
dysfunction happens whether it's the
coach gets another GM fired or the GM
gets the coach fired so you know
indications are it will be an O'Brien
guy right which means put everybody
together on the same page fused at the
hip equal accountability everybody
succeeds or everybody fails and if
you're gonna do this if you're gonna
hire a new GM while you're getting ready
for a football season with a head coach
in place it only makes sense to do it
that way yeah it does
I mean as much as this firing I think
caught us all you know you know by
surprise to it to a degree we had heard
some of these rumblings there and you
know our
oddly enough this is where I would I
would say with would Billy O'Brien I
mean I think he's a hell of a coach I
mentioned that kind of similarities with
the Jets you know it's a good time to
try to find the next GM your football
team right now this is the appropriate
time to make this move there's nothing a
front office is doing they're getting
ready to go on vacation for a few weeks
here in a few days so there this is the
time to do it and we even saw we felt
like the Jets process and hiring Joe
Douglas got kind of expedited once the
Texans fired Gaines because I would bet
they were a little scared that they
might call Joe Douglas and make hey you
know we'd like to come down here and
talk to us but I just ultimately get the
feeling that's gonna shake out a little
like the New York Jets Mike Weir we're
gonna get a guy a GM we're just like
gates with Joe Douglas he knows them a
little bit so there's certainly a
relationship but they're not making a
hiring for a guy just to appease the
head coach or that guy I think that and
I think that's where these New England
guys come into play here for Billy
O'Brien I don't think Billy O'Brien's
ever gonna be happy down there until he
gets the organization run the way he saw
it run in New England I want to put a
period yeah right after there right I
don't think Billy O'Brien's ever gonna
be happy down there period it's just
look yeah 2016 yeah right when we're
trying to figure out at the end of the
year who's gonna stay and who's gonna go
cuz every year six to eight coaches are
fired or leave - all of a sudden late in
the season there was an overwhelming
sense that Bill O'Brien was going to be
gone from the Texans not because he has
an issue with Houston he had an issue
with the Texans with the structure and
like you said he's trying to make it
into a quasi Patriots organization the
question is will new owner Cal McNair
allow him to do that
and can they put enough power on the
table to get a nick casera to serve and
want to leave he's been there 18 years
Chris
they've won six championships wouldn't
you want to hang around for number seven
no I do you want to go I mean really
right do you want to become a GM of a
new team in June the Hays already in the
barn your hands are already tied for the
2019 season yeah no you're right
they are they're tied there's no heavy
lifting to do other than he's gonna get
started if you got a GM they're gonna
get started on guys I think could be you
know
mr. Kutz as far as training camp and you
start to build there but this gives the
new GM the chance to kind of get his
feet within the organization before he
has to worry about his first big test
which are free to see and the draft and
all of that so you know again I just
looked at it and look at guys you know
like a Knick Kesari oh who is up in New
England whose phenomenal and you're
right Mike he's in a spot where his gosh
all they do is win but at some point I
look into Caesarea and I have like the
ultimate respect for him he would be GM
candidate number one if Chris Simms was
running a football team I know that he
is amazing that way ultimately I would
think he'd want to call some shots and
maybe put his own stamp on a football
team I know he's brilliant he does a lot
of good things out there but we all know
who's making the final call up in New
England at the end of the day I mean it
doesn't matter if my if Nick acero says
blue blue blue blue blue blue is the
best you know if Belichick comes in and
says red it's gonna be red and that's
just what he has to deal with and I
wonder what point does he get sick of
that and wanted to his own thing yeah I
agree with you completely and how much
power will he have how much power will
be available for the new GM will the
Patriots be able to block any effort to
interview a Nick Caesarea or Imani
Austin Ford and if so will Bill O'Brien
and the Texans have to go to someone who
isn't currently tied to a team like a
Scott Pioli that may be the only way to
get a patriot way into Houston because
Pio Lee can be hired without any team
saying yes or no to the potential
interview based upon the power that's
available so very intriguing and the
clock is ticking I'm sure they'd like to
have this done by the time training camp
opens because Chris you know how it goes
the moment camp opens guys get injured
yes guys don't perform well guys need to
be replaced
you better have somebody who's making
those calls who can bring new guys in
because the coach doesn't have time to
screw around with yeah you're right and
I think that was probably part of the
problem with Brian games I would look at
it and go man they had offensive line
issues last year they were very slow to
replace guys put the guys together they
had a few injuries where I'm sure it
just wasn't up to speed with Billy
O'Brien but yeah training camp is not
easy on a GM
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports